Congratulations, you've made your
first step towards a path in back-end
programming.
It's essential for back-end programmers
to understand databases in order to
design, debug and maintain applications.
In this next course, you'll learn about
the basics of SQL, database design,
and Python API for
connecting Python code to a database
by creating a game tournament.
As you dive into back-end programming,
there may be times where
you reach your strain zone.
I encourage you to use
the Udacity forums for support.
By the end of this course, you should
have a better idea of whether back-end
programming is the right fit for you.